the debate now i look to makila peterson
to continue the case for opposition
[Applause]
i'm michaela peterson and it's my
pleasure to oppose the house's motion
that we should move beyond meat
i rewrote my entire speech an hour ago
and decided just to embrace my story
because my life isn't actually focused
on spreading a meat diet around i have a
podcast and other things to do but i
live this every day so i'm here to talk
about it
my i'll start with my absolute absurd
health experience that's received
widespread negative media attention on
top of being fairly unpleasant to live
through
the reason for that negative media
attention was because
my diseases were put into complete
remission by an all-meat diet
no plant food so i i understand where
heather's coming from when she cut eggs
and dairy because those were so hard on
me it was unbelievable
but it wasn't the meat a very brief
background
i was diagnosed with juvenile rheumatoid
arthritis when i was seven with symptoms
starting when i was two i had 37
affected joints i spent 16 years
being treated with immunosuppressants i
injected twice weekly starting when i
was eight
and then other medications to treat my
many other diagnosed health ailments
chronic fatigue and severe absolutely
crippling depression
i lost my hip and my ankle that's why i
wore this skirt so you can see this
to
arthritis
um
and had them replaced when i was 17.
i tried going the medical route
and it didn't work when i was 23 my skin
had started to break down from rashes
and those stopped healing
i couldn't sleep on my shoulders and i
was so mentally unstable i couldn't have
a relationship my right wrist felt like
it was going to be next for my third
joint replacement anyway
i went back to school for biomedical
science and i decided to reduce my diet
dramatically just to rule it out not
because i thought it had anything to do
with my health
i cut it down to meat and whole foods
and within two months it eliminated
nearly all of my symptoms and i was
managed i managed to get off of ssris
and adderall and immune suppressants we
were absolutely
shocked
two months of that limited diet put me
into remission after 20 years of an
autoimmune disorder that destroyed my
joints
soon after that i had a baby and that
plus stopping my ssris way too quickly
brought my autoimmune symptoms back
along with ssri withdrawal depression
i can't begin to describe the level of
terror of having diseases return and
losing my mind to depression again
a year later again out of sheer
desperation
to eliminate my autoimmune symptoms and
depression i reduced my diet further and
i went down to just meat and i knew that
that wasn't bothering me based on how i
could feel after i ate it i figured you
can't be allergic to meat
i thought i was only going to be on that
for a month and then i was going to be
able to reintroduce foods back in and
eat normally however that wasn't the
case it took six months for my
autoimmune symptoms to go away but then
they did and my depression went away
and i was in remission again now since
then i've tried to reintroduce plant
foods because i actually like cake and
fruit and other foods and i don't really
want to be on this diet but i can't
introduce anything without having my
autoimmune symptoms come back
so
one of the arguments might be might say
and this is what happened with the media
too is okay maybe this girl is just this
one girl but my family is on this diet
because they have on autoimmune
disorders
so then it was well maybe this family is
just a strange family but i have a we
are a strange family okay so that that's
definitely true
uh
but uh i've got a facebook group now and
this is just small to start by the
facebook group now that with 7 000
people who have all been brought to this
diet because they've tried the medical
route they have no other options and
they're miserable and they're recovering
from diseases
the ketogenic diet which is the type of
diet i'm on minus the plant food has
been shown to treat epilepsy since the
1920s and was kind of put out of fashion
by anti-epileptics which aren't as
effective but are easier to adhere to
than the diet
one in nine people above the age of 65
have alzheimer's which is now being
referred to as type 3 diabetes induced
by carbs and sugar there's no bcd
epidemic in america
with 36 percent of americans overweight
and 32 percent obese
one in five people there have an
autoimmune disorder like me
one in six people are on a psychiatric
medication which are almost impossible
to get off of
like i was
a potential solution that should be
seriously looked into is radically
simplifying diet with fewer ingredients
going back to a time when we weren't all
chronically ill
and that involves dramatically
increasing red meat consumption and
decreasing plant foods
the demonization of red meat was based
off of a few hypotheses based on
observational studies that have been
proven to be false
saturated fat has slowly been
disappearing as the cause for heart
disease in scientific literature because
it's not the cause for heart disease
the studies on colorectal cancer we're
done on people who also ate more sugar
and processed foods mcdonald's
the need for fiber is a myth when you
don't consume plants
our populations need
high levels of vitamins it turns out
that's only necessary because we're
consuming so many carbs we can't handle
the amount of sugar in our body as soon
as you eat more meat and less processed
food that need goes away and vitamin
deficiencies recover
i think what people should be focused on
more than anything else is making other
people healthier can you imagine a
population
where obesity was non-existent and
autoimmunity and mental health wasn't a
concern
you have no idea who's out there dying
of a lifestyle caused disease that could
get healthy and fix our climate issues
and forcing the reduction of the amount
of meat eaten
a somewhat narcissistic venture under
the assumption that you know what these
new man-made foods do for people's
bodies better than two million years of
evolution something evolution could
produce is a massive and dangerous
mistake
we've evolved eating meat the food and
fat that enabled us to develop the
brains we have
assuming we can replace that with
something we've created
naive
and how dare we
as a first world country and developed
nation
spread word around the world that eating
meat is immoral and unhealthy
in areas the world where women can't
work or own land they can usually own
ruminant animals
that gives them and their families money
food and a job
in places like kenya people's diets are
mainly starches
not out of choice
and there are studies showing that
adding meat into these children's meals
increases their test scores by 45
if you use meat as a first food for a
baby their head circumference is
actually larger than babies fed without
meat
my main concern is people eating
healthily and meat is the healthiest and
most improperly villainized food out
there
ruminant meat is the only food that
people can actually survive on as a
single food without supplementing
anything else which is the perfect
elemental diet for a sick person
i wouldn't wish what i went through on
anyone
and i want to reduce the suffering so
badly that i'll stand here and tell you
that only eating meat seems
might
put certain diseases into remission
i get where the negativity comes from
it's unbelievable it's so unbelievable
that in the first study on the carnivore
diet released by harvard this november
that i actually read in the oxford
university press two days ago which was
convenient
uh they ended the study with contrary to
common expectations adults consuming a
carnivore diet experienced few adverse
effects
and instead reported health benefits and
high satisfaction the generalizability
of these findings and the long-term
effects of this dietary pattern require
further study
the surprise came because an average of
90 percent of people saw improvements
across all diseases on the diet
one in four people over 64 have type 2
diabetes in america all respondents with
diabetes discontinued non-insulin
injection agents
84 discontinued oral medication and 92
percent of participants on the carnivore
diet with type 2 diabetes discontinued
insulin altogether over 2000 people were
studied who were on the diet for over
six months
and there was a 90 reduction in all
diseases
in my opinion this type of potential
treatment for disease needs to be
studied further
before we move beyond meat
thank you
you